entre los condenados soy figuran algunos
de los más conspicuos activistas y
políticos de la oposición esta jimmy lai
magnate de la prensa el propietario del
apple daily un tabloide que se hizo
célebre con las chafarderías de las
celebridades locales y que también
ejerce de martillo pilón contra pekín y
el gobierno de hong kong la y está
procesado también por colusión con
fuerzas extranjeras por sus reuniones
con mike pence mai pompeu john bolton y
otros halcones de la anterior
administración estadounidense la iv es
considerado por la mitad de la población
japonesa como un héroe y por la otra
como un traidor está también martín lee
un abogado octogenario y exparlamentario
que es conocido como el padre de la
democracia en hong kong porque fundó el
partido democrático la formación bandera
de la oposición y ésta también le un
cojón más conocido como pelo largo por
razones obvias un pionero que ya luchó
contra el colonialismo británico desde
su formación trotskista y que después
tras el regreso de hong kong a china
llevó sus tácticas de guerrilla y sus
camisetas del cheque
al parlamento en unos tiempos en los que
los pragmáticos con con eses
consideraban una excentricidad las
reivindicaciones pro democráticas